the jurgen experience where do you think
you're going to wind up
i don't know tex is very interesting to
me that's very interesting i mean
the idea of that is very interesting i
put up the bat signal for everybody
yeah i mean that's very interesting to
me i mean i also think uh
you know i do like la but i don't know
what's gonna happen i do like it here i
mean they're
you know i don't know what i'm gonna do
i may manage you know i've talked about
managing logan paul's presidential
campaign i could always move back to do
that
um we're gonna have to talk to jake
though okay he's gonna be like roger
clinton
he's in trouble right now well there's a
few guns he's not in trouble he's got a
few you got an arsenal
he's like billy carter he's got an
arsenal beer
yeah yeah there's always a roger clinton
there's always a brother who you go
you take you just sit down was it an
arsenal thing or was
uh because he was he was stealing things
from the mall
i think he was just walking around the
mall being being what he does which is
with a camera and then i think you know
he left i think an ak-47 on his hot tub
like leaned up against the hot tub i
think somebody ratted them out and then
you know
did you show it on twitter or something
yeah there was something on instagram or
something
but dude a guy like that with that kind
of money i say get more weapons get up
gotta buy a weapons lab you should have
a back corona virus going 24 7.
get anthrax jake paul get anthrax who
cares
you're going to need it when la falls
these are the only [ __ ]
you know that are going to be able to do
anything they're going to have arsenals
that's a good point
yeah man why not it's not a bad idea
yeah
but i don't know like la's very weird
because you're you're like where do i
fit in you know without stand-up comedy
or like i podcast and that's
good and i try to make that as funny as
i can but then you look around a lot of
places of la like i don't really fit in
with the actors
and i'm not really one of these kids
it's really like a social media guy
and then i'm not one of these comment
these writers that you know tweet about
global warming and black lives matter
all day
so you look you're like my community of
people which was the store
and the stand-up comedians are have now
been like dispersed
so it's like a weird like i'm like a man
without a country yeah i feel like that
too and i want to be adopted by one of
these like someone
come in here like one of these youtubers
i don't care
anybody one of these guys that walk
around you know like high beasts and
these crazy shirts and everything just
i'll be one of those guys just
someone knocking on my start your own
thing well i mean
golf shirts and just screaming yeah just
just polos just like this just
ill-fitting polos
ill-fitting polos for the american
racists
polos are a weird choice pier like why
is it that that is like
the only thing i wear for dorks wear you
know what it is i i i've always wanted
to look like i've had money and i've
never
looked like it and there's a type of guy
that's from
a lot of them live in new york or long
island or boston by the way yes
yes and they wear these [ __ ] polos
and they have no [ __ ] money and
that's the kind of guy that i am where
it's like
i always want to look but they're always
sunburned
and they've always got like an
ill-fitting thing like the collars like
his collars all [ __ ] up
cause i tumble dry it in the wash like
an animal
i look like like a golf pro who's failed
at everything
his wife laughed like john daly's
brother yeah yeah i mean
but that's the look when you have the
look you just honor the look the izod
look i remember when i was a kid i have
fake eyes odds
we couldn't afford uh alligator okay so
what was it you have like an armadillo a
[ __ ] thing you buy from like
you know some stupid department store
yeah and guys would glue
uh an alligator over it oh really
depressing
oh that's rough yeah well they would
fake it you made it out
but
[Applause]